former president Donald Trump has
claimed that Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis owes his success to Donald
Trump's Administration and that
hypothetical presidential bid would be
insulting Iran would have not been
Governor if it wasn't for me so when I
hear he might run I consider that very
disloyed which by the way he is right if
it wasn't for Trump's endorsement Ron
doesn't win governorship I mean whether
you like Trump or you like the scientist
or you're going to vote Republican
Ticket No Matter What or you don't like
either one of them that endorsement
helped him get he won by 34 000 votes
the Santas responded to Trump's comments
by citing his recent Landslide victory
for with Florida voters well look what I
would say uh would just say is this I
roll out of bed I have people attacking
me from all angles the Santa said and
the good thing is that the people are
able to render a judgment on that
whether they re-elect you or not the
scientist was overwhelmingly re-elected
in November for a second term leading
Florida and won the highest percentage
of the vote that any Republican governor
candidate has in the history of a
state's history he also won by the
largest raw vote margin of one and a
half million votes than any governor
candidate has ever had in their Florida
history the verdict has been rendered by
the people of the State of Florida okay
which by the way you go from winning by
34 000 votes and you go winning one and
a half million votes and you win Miami
day you win you mean date you and this
is what he did is absolutely
unbelievable to validate how great of a
job he did for four years but that
doesn't mean mean Trump's endorsement
didn't help him win and without Trump's
endorsement he wouldn't want anyways Pat
just going up because he said he claimed
that he you know he owes him for the
success I'm going to be 100 honest with
you me living in California not really
in the political world I didn't hear who
I don't know the governor of Florida I
didn't know anything about that Trump's
attitude towards the medium being bold
and then all of a sudden I did start
seeing DeSantis started becoming that
guy where I was like oh that oh my God
he's kind of like him where he's calling
out the you know pointing at people
telling reporters in their face I don't
know if it was the Trump like attitude
or the Mystique but that type of
attitude I've seen come like Harry Lake
and all these very interesting points
isn't that weird and this is coming from
a guy that lives in California that's a
veteran that never gave a damn about
politics then I started seeing covid and
it was during covet where DeSantis was
like no no we're not going to be like
these people and that Drew the attention
to him because he was Trump like you
feel me so I mean say what you want I
think a little bit of that attitude
didn't brush off on them the most
impressive thing of desantis's win for
governor in 2022 was that he took
Hillsborough County I know Miami-Dade is
often very much liberal there is no more
liberal county in the state of Florida
than Hillsboro that's Tampa St
Petersburg that is where Charlie Crist
resides that's his hometown and he beat
Charlie Crist by how many votes 40 000
votes oh damn
so if you look at basically if you want
to give if you want to call each of
trump and DeSantis a stock yeah right
clearly one has been on the upswing
since 2020 and one has been on the major
decline since 2020. um and shots fired
by the way because DeSantis does not
respond to Trump he takes it he takes it
he takes it but read into exactly what
he said and the good thing is that the
people are able to render a judgment on
that on whether they re-elect you or not
read between the lines here he's
basically saying I got reelected by a
landslide you did not
sorry to inform you and we often say
that if not for covid Trump would have
probably been re-elected 100 if not for
covid we probably wouldn't all know Ron
desantis's name I agree with you you
don't know the random Governor from a
state doesn't matter no the reality is
kovid was uh Trump's Achilles heel and
kovid was what made Ron DeSantis I agree
so we'll see what happens right now at
this point if you look at the numbers
you know I'm a big Vegas guy it is now
the sentences election to lose wow he's
passed Trump in the primary polls and
we'll see what happens but we've got a
long road ahead no doubt but but here's
the thing though love them or hate them
don't you think just being Trump
wouldn't you be furious if from even
before you got in or you got called that
you won the Department of Justice with
the FBI with Peter struck and all these
freaking guys with Hillary Clinton all
colluding the actual collusion was the
left and then bro that all that
presidency and then covet everybody
every the whole swamp against you don't
you think he kind of wants to come in
and have a shot where all that [__] is
already done and you could be like all
right I'm coming in wrong now you guys
can't play that Russia [__] again all
the all the all the colluding all that
[__] no no now I'm coming in without all
you guys all the Deep State behind me I
mean I would be a pissed off number one
but number two I would tell the people
hey guys how about give me a shot
without everybody against me let me yeah
I'm gonna talk [__] yeah I'm gonna be
Brash but give me a chance you know what
I mean because be honest it wasn't fair
it wasn't love him or hate him it wasn't
fair and then covet comes I mean how
much [__] could go wrong for one guy be
honest I hear you I hear you you're
making a good case here but I think this
is one thing I will say there's nothing
uglier than politics obvious
presidential politics so when you enter
the ring you know exactly it's gonna be
a mud slinging contest Galore you don't
think DeSantis is literally emotionally
spiritually mentally getting ready God
bid you run
every disgusting thing you've ever done
is gonna be exposed what was great about
Trump is talk about 10 flaw Dawn anyone
grab them by the police they're done
they're yeah they're cats in their
campaign
hell yeah I did that locker room talk
buddy so it yeah it's a dirty dirty game
you better be ready but when your own
government and the Department of Justice
as you're a sitting president is
illegally going by and then nothing
happens to them welcome to politics
it's horrible but no but but you're 100
right Donald nobody's been shot he's
wounded he has like what else can you
say about me bro Stormy Daniels
yeah by the way before the Stormy
Daniels lawyer whatever happened to that
guy whatever happened with him you have
any thoughts on this or no yeah I think
you know I see it both ways I I look at
I look at Trump and I say look here's a
guy that used his personal political
Capital you know whether you love him or
hate him he used his personal political
Capital to help Ron DeSantis at a key
time and Ron DeSantis is not governor
and does not launch the bigger phase of
his political life without that
endorsement and
Trump is saying listen I lost but I'm
going to get ahead of seam I'm going to
get the band back together
some will be with me some won't but I'm
going to get it back together and I'm
going to run again and I think he's told
everybody that in Whispers
and he is disappointed that the sanus is
putting together a campaign to go run
unfortunately this is not you know
King's X this is not the way it works I
mean you look at the you look at the the
Democrat field Hillary was running I am
running and I'm gonna go and everybody
stay out of the way nope Obama ran all
those people stepped up when it's time
to run for president it's a Adam you're
it's the way to say it it is such a
dirty game and you have to keep
reminding yourself as you analyze it
this is Dirty by Design yeah right say
how Hillary's like I was Secretary of
State I'm smart as hell I had the first
Healthcare initiative I have all these
things stay the flip out of my way no
there was nine people on stage with her
and Obama beat her
um and you know that just that's just
the way this works yeah so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]